voici l'histoire de ma déchéance
ce n'était pas comme ça avant mais un
mois plus tôt haarde machin vous êtes
philosophe je me la pète joueur d'échecs
en plus avocat pénaliste pas trop dur la
pression chez vous auriez dû lui mettre
la tête dans son cas ce bâtard sa tête
une option bonne journée nous saluent
maman je dois parodie un film français
et c'est super galère ils y ont pu faire
un gens qui arrivent et oui une seule et
jean-pierre comment tu vas ah c'est toi
maman m'a dit que tu travaillais sur
simone de beauvoir
ouais simone de beauvoir les bonnes ok
je vais travailler alors à mon petit
frère tu devrais changer de cheveux on
va passé de super moments ensemble super
à jean pierre jean pierre jean de luz
tard les cantons jus d'orange tu le veux
avec ou sans fil jusqu'au jour où il va
découvrir
alors j'ai découvert ne faut pas
s'affoler mais vous avez le htc dé la
jeunesse qu'il n'a jamais eu les
techniques du joueur et concrètement ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
êtes redevenu intéressant vous allez
faire des trucs de données sans sortir
mode vibreur profondeur vas-y c'est quoi
la touche pour la passion que vous allez
aussi magique comme les j'arrive quoi ai
je voulu cette jambe qui tourne en kemal
oui la viande qui tourne mal tu avais je
connais un caisson plus en afrique et en
verlan quoi qu'un free age of ages
pensez vous parlez de la police faudrait
un temps la vie comme le faisait rare
est avec il faudra faire ce qu'ils le
sont voilà je suis trop swag sac oblige
à nous ensuite et c'est nous qui sont la
dream team
hu
j'emmerde je savais que tu fait adopter
kemal ouais je t'ai boucher ou quoi oui
un kebab